Goldie Hawn makes her long-awaited
return to the big screen with Amy
Schumer the oscar-winning actress tells
ET how the comedian put an end to her
14-year hiatus Goldie's last movie was
the banker sisters in 2002 what about
this movie brought Goldie Hawn back to
the big screen because everyone is so
excited had to be funny and it had to be
with the right person I did a lot of
stuff but if it can't live up the
expectation it's not worth doing and
having joy fun working where you're
gonna work with someone who you admire
and adore and having and it's the whole
movie together we are on quite a romp
together the two of us in the jungle
it's just gonna be a blast you know so
that's what brought me back last
question I saw you were facetiming with
Amy's dad and that was such a sweet
moment what was that like for you you're
the love of his life you guitar I love
my life because it was so true he's so
real and you see this is why Amy's real
I was uncensored or whatever she may be
she speaks right from her heart and
she's a great great daughter and a great
sister I really loved her